now to ukraine where officials are
urging residents of keeve not to return
home today as the capital region comes
under renewed fire from russian forces
the latest attacks come as the un's
human rights commission delivers a grim
update more than 1900 civilians are now
estimated to have died since the war
broke out more than 160 of them children
reggie chichini looks at the latest
russian offensive that's targeting major
cities across the country and a warning
some of the images in this story are
disturbing
this is a grim sign in a city hanging by
a thread
russia claiming it's in control of a
steel plant in mariupol one of the last
remaining outposts of the ukrainian
forces in that city an attack on a
makeshift military installation that
resulted in civilian loss russians have
shown that they are willing to use
anything and everything to try and
subjugate our country russia now claims
it's cleared all ukrainian troops from
mariupol and if so it would mark a first
victory if confirmed keeve says that
would end talks with moscow
but the military push still continues
across besieged luhansk
while shelling proved deadly in harkev
hitting an administrative building
the blast wave partially damaged nearby
buildings including an apartment this
official says
moscow has threatened to increase its
attacks possible retaliation for the
sinking of a warship the kremlin claims
was due to a fire
in levive the easter end passover
weekend brought new threats where its
reported russian missiles were taken out
by the country's air defense system for
us there is no question here we're
fighting for our very existence for our
future
fighting that's earned soldiers the
respect of their president who awarded
the medals on saturday for bravery in
the past against the agony of the
present
we put a photo of him there he was
always smiling says this mother whose
son died fighting for ukraine
she's afraid russia will return and
destroy this graveyard in tortillanest
one dotted with landmines
unthinkable atrocities are now an
everyday thought with more than 900
civilians already recovered from mass
graves around kiev
now under the threat of a more intense
fight in the east lies the evergreen
request for more weapons from the west
hundreds of millions of dollars worth
are being sent this weekend but
officials in the united states fear that
could be expended
within days of arrival
reggie chikini global news washington